I have a bit of a history with monorails
back in 2016 I visited the vopital
suspended monorail in Germany and I said
that monorails are almost always a bad
idea monorail enthusiasts sent me angry
messages but I stand by that in 2020 I
visited one of the last surviving road
machines cargo monorails they were
actually useful and practical but they
were temporary constructions designed
for having cargo hauled around work
sites and they've been replaced by
modern heavy construction equipment
monorails are usually bad ideas because
the track has to be either elevated or
in a trench and because switches at
Junctions involve moving the whole track
in almost every case and monorail is a
worse and more expensive idea than light
rail or a tram or a bus
but while I was researching a while ago
I found a type of monorail that is
useful and practical and better than any
alternative for its job and not only is
it still in use new versions of it are
being built so I reached out to the
company that makes them and I asked them
can I have a go on one please this is
the monarac
we built mainly rope waves that's our
main business everything
with the Rope aerial tramways chair
lifts ski lifts and Monarch is a
governmental product since nearly 45
years in 1978 they single or 79 some two
years after the petrol Monarch they
start with the electricity they
installed mainly in the Alp area Germany
Switzerland a lot of monorax in Italy
but also Canada Sweden Asia all over the
world we have more or less about 800
monoraks the petrol monorax are mainly
installed in the agriculture area the
electrical monologue usually is quiet
but here the customer made its own box
that's the reason why it's still a
little bit loud the invention that makes
this thing so useful is down on the
track this is a rack Railway so the
track has grooves and the cogs on board
the train lock into it that means it can
climb very steep hills like this and
take tight Corners with no risk of
slipping having just one lightweight
rail means it doesn't take up much room
it can go around tight corners and it's
easy to install being elevated means it
can go over rough terrain and if there's
rain or mud below it doesn't matter I
genuinely can't think of a better
solution for regularly safely moving
things up and down steep rough terrain
like this every monorak is based on that
brake and on a ancient chassis and
what's between the the two chassis is up
to the customer we can't choose
different models different chairs
whatever the customer needs or want you
can see the charging rails if the
customer wants two or three he can
choose two or three charging points
normally we have only one in one of the
end stations I know this sounds like an
advert I promise it isn't I just got
actually properly and enthusiastic about
being proved wrong there are useful
monorails in the world and this
this is one of them